when it comes to starting your youtube
channel one of the things that you might
be thinking about
is how long will it take before i can
actually make money with this project
well my name is heather torres with the
think team and i am so excited because
today i will be sharing
three ways that you can make money with
a small channel and
small channel obviously is relative to
whatever you think is small
but i'm gonna be sharing with you three
different ways that you can start making
money
right off your channel and i'll be
giving you case studies so you can see
channels just like yours doing this
right now but let's go to get right into
today's
training we're going to be talking about
how to make money with a
small youtube channel and i do have
three ways to do that the first
one is youtube ads now what's really
cool about youtube ads
is and youtube in general is that
youtube is one of the only platforms
that pays you to be a creator well i
know that
tick tock has you know ways that they
pay creators but it's a very small
percentage
youtube when you put in the work when
you put in the time when you actually
make good quality videos
they will open up what's called their
partnership program to you
now what's really great about that is
that once you are able to meet the
requirements of youtube ads
you can start earning money based on the
views on your videos well what does this
look like
in order to get qualified with the
requirements for youtube you do have to
have
one thousand subscribers and four
thousand four
thousand excuse me four thousand valid
public watch hours within a 12
month time span so what does that look
like it looks like
when you get started on youtube as you
start to post your videos
you're going to want to hit these two
main milestones which is a subscriber
goal
and a watch time goal that means how
many minutes how many hours
are people watching your videos once you
hit that threshold
you then unlock the potential to be able
to go deeper
into the youtube ad partnership program
now these are ads that can show up
at the beginning of your video they can
show up mid-roll in your video they can
show up at the end of your video they
can pop up on the screen on your video
they can come out on the side
there's a ton of different ways that you
can actually start monetizing your
channel
directly with youtube and we actually
just did a video here on the think uh
channel
where you can go and watch a one-hour
free video
all about the youtube monetization five
ways you can make money and how youtube
pays you to do it
sean candle from the think team walks
you through exactly
how to get set up on that partner
program because it's not done on youtube
it's done on a separate site
and how you can actually start to
utilize the youtube ad
strategy to start making money on your
channel and
here's an example of a channel from our
community the video ranking academy
community
and this is safari expert now i think
this is so cool
i've watched so many of their videos
because i want to go on a safari
and they're a channel that goes through
uh different safari
group trips you can go on they talk
about different um different safaris and
and they go really deep into that world
well
here's a testimonial that they just gave
us they said that well now that they're
almost at 6 000 subscribers
once they got to their 1 000 subscribers
and their four hours of watch time
they started making on average 230
dollars a month
off of their channel and they are just
getting started so
while 230 dollars may not seem like
a ton of income right off the bat
here's the thing it's proof of concept
this is showing that as you go through
making the content on your channel
as you go through uploading more and
more videos that are getting more and
more views
you start to unlock the potential to be
able to get
monetized on your channel now youtube
ads isn't actually the only way and
really
here at think it's not actually the
first way
that we recommend that you start
monetizing your channel
youtube ads are great and here
personally at think media we're able to
run our entire youtube channel off of
the ads alone because it's able to
monetize enough
but that takes a few years to build up
to one of the youtubers
that i watch named graham stefan he just
did a whole analysis you know those
videos where
they go over like how much did youtube
pay me for this many views
we just went over what he made last year
on youtube
and my friend it was in the millions of
dollars
just off ads alone so the potential
starts at 230 dollars
but it can unlock a massive amount of
potential
i could use an extra million i don't
know about you but i would love an extra
million
off of my youtube channel and here's the
thing to remember as you're making
content on youtube
remember that it is one of the only
platforms that partners
with their creators and they are
investing heavily
into making that a great partnership
instagram doesn't do that
facebook doesn't do that pinterest
doesn't do that
as you are pouring your time and your
energy into making good
content the reason we recommend youtube
and the reason we recommend being a part
of their partnership program
is because as you start to grow and as
you start to get views on your channel
you can start to get paid to be a
creator
this is how you can go full time on
youtube but again
adsense is not the first way that we
recommend that you monetize
your channel the second way that you can
start making money on youtube with a
small channel is affiliate marketing
and this is actually the number one way
that we think that a lot of creators
should get started
on youtube with monetizing their channel
you can do this with video number one
if you are set up on a good quality
affiliate marketing program now
you might be asking questions like well
what is affiliate marketing affiliate
marketing to me
is just a cool way for you to get paid
for
sharing products and services that you
love and
use there's a couple keywords in there
products and services
meaning that there are affiliate
marketing programs for just
about everything and i'm going to show
you an example
of some affiliate marketing programs
that are not just
amazon i know that's usually the first
one that you hear about and that's one
of the ones we recommend because it is
amazon's the store of everything but it
doesn't necessarily need to be the only
affiliate marketing program that you
sign up for here at think we are a part
of i think now over 30 different
affiliate marketing programs
that are off of amazon that are totally
unrelated to what amazon sells
but they are bringing in checks every
single
month you know i remember when i was
younger and i had that idea of like you
know what would be cool
i just like opened my mailbox and there
was checks in there that's what
affiliate marketing
does you start to get paid residual
on things that people are purchasing
that you've recommended in your videos
products and services and this can work
for almost every single niche
there is a product or service for almost
every single niche
and i bet you there's a list of things
that you could be recommending to the
people who are watching
your content so an example of that uh
actually if you want to go deeper on
affiliate marketing we actually have a
podcast the think marketing podcast
and you can watch episode number 26 or
episode 27 it's a part one and part two
over on our think marketing podcast and
we go deeper into what is affiliate
marketing how do you get signed up for
affiliate marketing
how can you position your content best
for affiliate marketing
and we go deep into it on those two
30-minute sessions
that you can get for free right now on
our podcast but i said i would share an
example with you
of a uh creator who is actually using
this strategy affiliate marketing off of
amazon and is creating a
full-time income is able to go full-time
just off of affiliate marketing and
adsense okay so
i actually met al over on clubhouse
al popped into one of the clubhouse
rooms that i was hosting uh
and he was telling me all about how he
has less than 3
000 subscribers and he is sharing
products with his
audience the uh eat more vegans um
channel he's sharing all these different
products meats
and and torches and grills and all these
things
and what's so cool about what al's doing
is that he is actually able to
create an income off of his channel with
less
than 3 000 subscribers and one of the
things that he does is in his
description
he's actually labeling a ton of
different affiliates that he could be
uh helping his people with so on here
you're seeing like thermoworks
thermapen that links to a
specific one or the john bose butcher
block
table that's an amazon link but what's
really cool
is that al from eat more vegans actually
sends people to this uh silver
river farms this is a high-end
meat farming company and they they are a
full-on you know
um ranch and he sends people
here to get the meat and what's so cool
is that if you're into good meats if
you're into good selection and you are
into barbecuing you're not just buying
one steak you're buying
a lot of things on residual orders and
so he's getting affiliates
every single month that people are
putting in orders over and over again
are you seeing the value of what can
happen with affiliate marketing
this is another one of our uh video
ranking academy students hammer and home
and what i love that they're doing is
they do uh home renovations they do tiny
home renovations
and they're about to start a brand new
project but in between their projects
what they do is they actually review all
of the tools
that they are using for their projects
so not only do you get to see what
they're doing
in the really cool production that they
have but on top of that
they're actually sharing the different
tools that they're using they're
affiliated with
um with a home depot and lowe's
and online on amazon they've got um
direct
to the actual manufacturer i mean
they're really understanding
the different ways you can go into this
and if you're searching
for a no touch temp check
you're probably gonna buy one and so
they're setting themselves up
for success when it comes to being able
to do affiliate marketing so
let me know in the comment section below
are you doing affiliate marketing yet
yes or no i'd love to hear from you all
right number three number three and then
we're actually going to get into some q
a
number three is to sell something number
three is to
sell something what's so cool about
youtube is that it can be a marketing
channel
for your existing business so if you're
a service-based business provider
if you want to be growing a business on
and off of youtube
well this is the channel for you and a
great way that
even with a small audience you're
actually able
to start generating an income now it may
not be hundreds of thousands of dollars
right away
but the proof of concept is always in
the smaller numbers
that help you grow and grow and grow so
selling something this is a really cool
testimony um from
jonathan jonathan is from destructive
creative
and he has a pretty uh really a fairly
new
youtube channel excuse me fairly new
youtube channel
and he uh he's at under 3 000
subscribers
and what's so cool about what he's doing
is that he set himself up for success so
on top of his youtube channel that he's
using as a marketing arm for his
business
he actually just told us that he's made
50 000
in sales from his membership courses and
programs that he has he's set them up
for
inexpensive prices for different ages
and he's teaching
uh science and history and geography and
he's allowed himself to create an entire
full-time business
around his youtube channel what's so
cool too is he was contacted by
the girls guide and he's now a paid
person like a paid teacher on their site
as well they found him through
his youtube channel so the marketing
capability of selling something
is amazing i could use an extra fifty
thousand dollars off of core sales
online right uh this is also reminds me
of cami
um she's from plant based kitchen so
here i am i got the carnivores
i got the vegans today okay so i'm not
discriminating against either right now
right so you choose you okay
but uh cammy from the plant-based
kitchen she's at now uh
almost at 3 000 subscribers but what i
love so much about what kimmy did over
the holidays
is she did a beautifully designed
thanksgiving
ebook she sold this ebook through her
website for 15
now cami was over uh just a couple
months ago and she told me that she'd
already generated a few
hundred dollars off of her ebook now
again
that's not necessarily life-changing
she's not quitting her career yet
but what it is is proof of concept she
now has this asset that she can sell
over and over on autopilot because she's
created the youtube
videos that are selling something i hope
you're getting value out of this today
hit the like button if you are
and i want to tell you about omar omar
is from our think team
omar actually uh was a contractor here
at think media before he came
on to the team and what omar did is he
created actually
some presets for his channel now his
channel now is at 24
000 subscribers which is relatively
big um but when he first got started
he actually created a a preset package
i didn't even know what a preset package
was but omar created this
and it actually is just a way that you
can put on
the filters to your pictures he sold
this for 25 dollars he
created a digital product sold it for
twenty five dollars
omar told me that he was able to pay his
mortgage
because of this twenty five dollar
product
now you just need to sell something so
my challenge to you is what do you need
to sell
what do you have that you could actually
start selling online
are you a coach do you have coaching
programs are you a real estate agent can
you sell houses
are you a financial advisor can you sell
different checklists
or different workbooks or different
seminars that can allow you to create
income off of your channel you know here
at think media this is actually
one of the ways we were able to
massively scale our company
we started with just the youtube channel
and affiliate marketing so we had ads
and affiliate marketing but when we
added on the education side of the
company when we started to sell
something that was ours
we went into the multiple seven figures
we're able to employ
full-time people and we're able to
expand our reach into the millions
in this space all of that happened
because we started to do the one two
three
we started to get adsense do affiliate
marketing
and then sell something and
i want to just review that really quick
these are the three different ways that
you can actually start making money with
a very small channel
you can start with youtube ads you can
go to affiliate marketing
and then you can start to sell something
now if you are thinking
heather i want to learn more ways to be
making money online
well my friend chalene johnson is
actually putting together a brand new
five day challenge that you can sign up
for
right now it starts this week i'm gonna
be taking the challenge and she's gonna
be helping you learn
ten different lucrative ways that you
can make money
online right now and she's even gonna
teach you
one business that you can start today
what i love about what she's teaching is
she's teaching you some of the easy ways
to make money
with zero experience and you'll learn
how to
increase your sales turn your passion
into profit
and you'll also learn how to scale and
grow and branch out from there so if you
want to learn how to do that
you just need to go to idea to income
dot tips and get signed up with chalene
and myself and we will love to have you
inside of that
challenge now we are going to jump into
the q a part of today if you're getting
value-added today let me know
you are on right now with the think
marketing
show my name is heather taurez we're
gonna get cash
we're gonna drink some coffee
we're gonna do all the things i love
what evan said here evan said yeah a
course book and coaching
exactly that's what we want i want to
say welcome to
the uh show here evan says um what
should be the goal percentage to go full
time
really great question evan so here's
what we say it's a 25
rule so if you are working like a
full-time job
and you can figure out what is well
first off you need to declare what is
the goal
like let me know in the comments right
now what is full-time to you
because that's so relative to where you
are in your life stage
where you're living how baller you want
to be i mean for me
going full time on youtube in order to
make that happen
my husband and i we had to make some big
sacrifices in our family
so in order for us to go full time to be
able to not have to work corporate jobs
to not
have to um you know go and work for
someone else in order for us to be able
to go full time and do this
we actually decided to move so we moved
from
an expensive city into a less expensive
city we moved our family from washington
down to las vegas that was a huge
difference even in just the value of
home prices and things like that
when we got to las vegas we got a house
that house was a beautiful home
but when we decided we were going all in
when we were like no this is what we
want to do and we're going to make this
happen
we actually determined what that number
was that we needed to live off of
not ball or out but what we needed to
live off of like
heather's not going to starbucks i'm not
getting my nails done i was not getting
my eyelashes done
my husband was not golfing every week
like these are things where we're like
what expenses can we cut to figure out
what full time is that we need to
live off of sustainably with our family
because once we hit that full time
then we know we can scale past there but
what's that goal
and at the time my husband was making a
substantial
corporate salary and we were living in a
larger home and we were
at a life stage where we were very
comfortable but when we wanted to make
that switch we were like all right we
need to downsize our life
so we downsized our house half the size
half the cost
that was intense um but we did that
because that allowed us to go full time
faster
we drove older cars that were paid off
without car payments so we made that
happen and we started to really live
within our means i'm telling you all
this because a lot of times we
see these flashy things like make ten
thousand dollars in a month
how to go to six figures and it's like
that doesn't necessarily have to even be
full-time so
i'd love to hear what full-time means
for you but once you determine
what full-time is to you then what is
the percentage to go full-time is the 25
rule so if you and your side hustle
if you on your youtube channel can be
making 25
of whatever full time is for you while
you're still
working a full-time job or you're in a
full-time uh
position of some kind maybe it's
freelancing or whatever that looks like
if you can make 25 of that goal as a
side hustle
then if you were to quit your job you
had enough savings to make that last
you can actually go full time faster if
you're at 25
because without the 40 hours that you're
working over there putting that energy
in focus
into your actual one thing can actually
help you go full time
uh faster so we say 25 i feel very
comfortable and safe saying
i would not go into debt and then go
full time i would really start to work
through those things right i would that
was not a path i would recommend
but i would say if you want this to be
your job
if you wanted youtube to be your thing
then you're probably gonna have to make
some sacrifices along the way
to make this a possibility for you and
this is a possibility friends there are
a lot of people
going full time on youtube right now
because they've thought about it
they've made the plan they've made the
sacrifices they've made the commitment
to consistency
and they've gone all in so i hope that
helps evan and give some perspective
um on that hey tony from the think
team's gonna drop a link if you'd like
to come
on and ask a question he's gonna be
dropping a link inside of the comments
and that's where i can see uh that i
also want to say thank you so much for
the super chat love when i get some
super chats
um if you have any questions tony just
said it here if you have any questions
put that four question marks before and
after and that can help you um right
there so tony said
or tony uh says there's a question
thanks tony he's in the back
and i'm just looking at him um on my
channel i share communication tips for
professionals
uh what would be a great strategy to get
booked
by companies to do communications
workshops for them
well i would actually put together a
speaker reel
of some kind i think if you're gonna be
doing um any type of
communica if you basically want to get
on their books
one i'd figure out who's booking so i
would
really look at um uh who is the person
that's booking those events
find them on linkedin uh figure out who
their marketing person is
and then i would start to actually
create
some type of portfolio for yourself so
what talks have you done before
do you have a web page that shows people
you know what topics you like to talk
about
um i would really start to research i
would actually go to youtube this is
this is heather's life okay i don't know
the answer to a question
i go to youtube and find answer so i
would go and i would actually type in
uh um strategies for
um getting booked and i would go through
those strategies and see
what works all right uh looks like we
have matt on today matt's gonna come on
and ask us a question
hey matt how you doing hey this is zoo
nice to see you hey um let everyone know
who you are
what your channel is about and what
question i can answer for you
yeah sure so i'm a chess channel making
sure that i can teach
chess to people that are new experienced
and people that are on the ride for
the queen's gambit netflix series and uh
just encourage them yeah
um my question is once i get monetized
this
my channel is really young only three
weeks but once i get monetized
is it important that when i get
monetized in the funnel of um
cash goes into the adsense or whatever
is it important to have like a bank
account that i create to make sure that
i don't get taxed or
is it really another like other route
that you
recommend yeah really great question um
first i'll just start i am not a tax
professional i actually
really loathe learning about all that
stuff but i have to because i'm a
business owner right
um but actually in that video that i
recommended we'll make sure you get the
link to it
um shot actually explains that um in the
us it is actually taxable income so you
do
have to uh when you um sign up for the
youtube adsense
they are sending you a 1099 as a
contractor so
you have taxable income uh now
this is not tax advice but this is just
saying that when you start a business
there are benefits and tax write-offs so
you want to
you want to clean that income because it
actually can then help you with
additional write-offs like
all of your camera equipment could be
written off uh again not tax
professional just telling you what we've
done yeah um
you then have opportunities in uh your
office space at home and you know
different your internet and your cell
phone all these things that you're using
for business
they do become a tax write-off now we uh
did decide to make it a separate bank
account
so that we could show the income in that
bank account um
as a business income and that just
helped us uh
in that side versus it just going
directly into our own personal account
so
we did choose an opt to do a separate
bank account
i didn't set it up as a business account
i just went to my
local bank and just set up a new account
and linked that to my amazon
associates i'm sorry not my amazon my um
adsense yeah
my my amazon and my adsense it all goes
into one account so
that's what i would recommend matt and
definitely check out that video because
sean walks through
like step by step how to get signed up
in adsense when you get approved
mm-hmm yeah one more question before i
hop off is like
i'm thinking about as i get to you know
partnership or like no
like like a montage i want to have like
um
a mailing list and a website to make
sure that we get traffic
um i'm just trying to figure out is like
uh
i'm just like what's uh i know there's a
lot of discussions about um what's a
proper what like um email list
that is like attracting so one thing i
was thinking about as a model
eventually once i get a website and
basically it's going to be a freebie
that
people sign on to my email list and my
website
they'll be having a freebie for my
youtube channel
love it that's a great idea that is so
what strategy matt's talking about just
to give context
is that uh this is the strategy where
you're bringing the conversation
off of youtube because remember matt we
don't own anything on youtube right we
this is youtube is their own playground
that we're playing on
so we want to be able to bring people
that are interested in our things
off of youtube so we can deepen our
relationship and what you're doing is
you're giving them a
free offer of some kind and the exchange
for that
is your email list so yes your next step
is to get your website up
get an email provider like i'm using
wix.com right now for my homeschool
stuff
if you're not getting hundreds of
thousands of opt-ins i'm just getting
they're trickling in you know i probably
get 10 to 30 a week
that is working just fine i can export
that list and whenever i need to upgrade
to another service provider like
get response or constant contact or
or kajabi i will then have that list
already going but i would look at a
website email provider together
that helps you um to be able to do that
okay thank you so much
awesome thank you so much for coming on
hey how oh what matt come back on
come back on how is your channel doing
with the queen's gamut
like crazy yeah so i'm just looking i'm
working on sean cannell's um goal that
he suffered for me is like
this is like well it's the first time i
met you in january
so it was pleasant but you said 30
videos before
april it's like oh i'm on it so i've
i've been uh
right now like i'm six videos in but i
have been getting really good responses
i have 55 subscribers
and basically i'm just on the case
amazing i cannot wait okay when 30
videos happens come back on the show
because i want to look at everything
okay
yeah i'm planning on doing that and ever
also awesome thanks for being on that
so awesome oh i love people that are
taking action
and again we'll make sure that's linked
down below uh definitely go over and
watch that video if you have questions
about
how to set up your ad account with
youtube because it's actually not in
youtube
it's on a separate website called
adsense google
owns youtube so it's all part of like
the google network and all that kind of
stuff okay
uh taylor says what have you found to be
the best
be the best affiliate marketing programs
for a finance and investing channel oh
um taylor um things that have to do with
credit
so like all those credit things um
that'd be a good one for
finance and investing um uh you can do
different
um ones around i mean like even like
dave ramsey has affiliate marketing
that you could do so i would really be
searching about what apps they need
like i use a money app on my phone you
can be an affiliate
on the app store so you can actually get
a piece of when people download
apps so you could do apps software
programs um
especially in like investing um i won't
say robinhood but i know back then you
could do robinhood
you maybe could do robinhood still we'll
see how it all goes right i don't even
know what i'm talking about i had to
have tony explained it to me like a
fifth grader okay
but uh you can do affiliate marketing
for um a lot of different things and
here's what i'd say taylor
go study your competition what are they
promoting
what's in their um what's down below uh
theirs
i would actually there's probably a blog
post here's for everyone a challenge for
everyone
affiliate marketing programs for
niche whatever your niche is affiliate
marketing programs for
homeschooling i'll bet you there's a
blog that someone has written that has
21 ways that homeschoolers can make
money or
finance or investing so your task
is to actually go and search partnership
programs
for cooking channels right like there's
a ton of different ones
um amazon obviously taylor because you
can do books and things like that but
there are a lot
of different ways and i would start to
search different people who are in the
finance space
not even just on youtube i would look at
blogs
i would look in magazines i mean even
like tammy the example
that i showed here excuse me the example
i showed here um
they were at a local farmers market and
they get like
olive oil and stuff from and stuff like
other things they get olive oil from a
company that does olive oil
and she like made a deal with the
company right there she's like if i sell
oh you sell this online
if i sell this online can i get a cut
and the lady was like yeah
so even with like you can be creative
on how you do affiliate marketing all
right um let's see dennis says
do you have a list of affiliate
marketing groups you can share with us
dennis that would be amazing right um
you can actually
go to um you just go to youtube or
excuse me go to google
and uh it depends on your niche because
not every niche is gonna have that but
what an amazing download i'm taking
notes right now
that that even could be a download that
we do for different niches to help you
get
started so dennis really great i love
this wow
commitment is right evan all right i'm
gonna take uh one
more person i'm gonna take matthew um up
on the channel
hey matthew how you doing oh you're
muted
sorry i'm doing this
good tell everyone who you are what your
channel is and what question i can
answer for you
my name is matthew and i'm a huge fan of
the think media team
and i love this idea i have a youtube
channel
called camera329 and i can't wait to
make videos for all the people who want
to see more videos like that
i want to see more of questions and
answers
from my youtube channel you'll have to
review that
okay so we look at your youtube channel
what is it called again it's camo329
camo yep camo three
two nine yes ma'am oh there you are i
see ya
you've got two channels yeah
okay hang on let me get let me get this
screen share up here how long have you
been
creating youtube videos oh like about a
week
oh okay so you're just getting started
well that's why i was gonna say
i was gonna say one um let's bring this
up here so people can see what's going
on
all right we've got camo three two one
okay couple things
um i want you to this is good so you
you're doing uh different videos here
but here's what i want you to start
studying
we have a video on titles i want you to
look at different titles because the
titles you're using right now are not
going to
help you grow your channel because they
are not
searchable titles so one thing i want
you to do matthew is study um some of
our videos that we have here on think
where we talk about like three titles
you should use if you're under a
thousand subscribers do this
we have different videos like that
definitely watch those videos because i
want you to go
i want these to be great my video
adventure
i want to know what the topic is i want
to know what the story is and i want to
know if i were to be
searching what would i see so what is
your channel going to be about matthew
it's all about the reviews for other
people
on facebook anything like when i do
review videos and i do like
so much time that me and my mother does
it
amazing so that's what i would say i
would say i want you to really study
um have you taken our free master class
matthew
we have a free youtube class yeah
okay that's the next step for you and
everyone else to take that free youtube
class you can do it at
thinkmasterclass.com and i think that's
really going to help you grow your
channel i love that you jumped in i love
that you got started on youtube
i'm so pumped for your adventure and
thank you for being a part of the think
community
well thank you all right we'll talk soon
okay love that so much when we get to
see the different people uh part of the
think media i'm gonna take two more
questions and i gotta bounce
as a small channel right now how do you
think i could make money in the personal
development and self-development niche
well get up and go
go mo get up and go mentoring
you have so much opportunity in this
space one way that you can do this is
actually signing up as an
affiliate for other people who have
programs in this space so
um like right now here at think media
we have a signature program when you
sign up as an affiliate with us when you
become a member
and you sign up as an affiliate with us
we give you five hundred dollars every
time you sell our program
all you have to we have someone right
now who's making i think six thousand
dollars a month
just off of referring our program so
you can refer other people's programs
there's books there's courses
i would be thinking especially in the
personal development and
self-improvement
productivity right what other seminars a
lot of times
when there are different types of
seminars or
conferences they will do affiliates for
those conferences so are there
conferences in your niche that you could
sign up for
there's a lot of different ways you can
get started this is going to take some
planning and some
and some real thinking through what
you're going to be recommending to your
audience
but you have a ocean full of
possibilities
for you um to be able to do that well
hey just want to let you know that if
you are ready for your next step in
learning how to actually do youtube
uh but not just youtube but make money
inside hustles my friend chalene johnson
is hosting a five day challenge
where you're going to learn 10 different
ways that you can make money online i'm
teaching all about youtube
here but chalene and brock and brett
johnson
are going to be diving deep into how to
make money online and how you can start
a business today
i can let you know that my personal
journey and story wish lean johnson
started
over a decade ago i was a young mother
who was fighting through depression i
was overweight i was anxious
i was broke joking disgusted right i was
in debt
and i saw an opportunity of learning
from
a mentor chalene johnson and i dove
right in and
not only did she help me change my
mindset and my body my outlook on life
but literally my life has been changed
by learning the principles in business
that chalene and brett johnson have
taught me over the last decade and so
i highly endorse anything that chalene
is going to teach you i would not send
you in a direction
that would be totally off-putting but i
can tell you that the reason i'm able to
be sitting here right now in front of
this microphone sharing this with you
is because of the lessons that i've
learned from chalene so i definitely
recommend
that you sign up for her five day free
challenge where she's going to be
walking you through ways to make money
online in 2021 because here's the
reality folks
we need a plan b we have noticed over
this last year
that plan a may not be working out and
we want to help you
learn the online space by being able to
work through the different principles
and business tactics that chalene has
taught me i've been able to create
multiple streams of income that have
helped sustain my family
through one of the hardest years and i
just want you to have that opportunity
as well so make sure you go and sign up
at idea to income dot
tips for the five day free challenge i
will see you
over there and thank you so much for
being here you can click or tap the
screen for the next video and we'll
catch you on the next live